[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul aka the biggest gangster
on YouTube and this video we're breaking
down some of the big plot leaks that
we've heard about Avengers Secret Wars
cast your mind back to a couple of weeks
ago and you may remember that we did a
video discussing the future plans for
Sony's Spider-Man and how they'd be
integrating Andrew and Toby into future
films is included across the
spider-verse and Beyond with the actors
also returning for Secret Wars from what
I've been told it picked up a lot of
traction and though I did talk about
elements of Secret Wars in the video I
didn't go all out with what I'd heard so
I thought I'd do this follow-up to
discuss some of the details I've been
told also just to give my general
theories on what I think will happen in
the movie now take this all with a pinch
of salt as the script is still being
worked on and the final plot details
definitely won't be nailed down yet
however this is more of a rough idea of
what they plan to do and how the MCU
will look after the events that happen
in phase six I know right now you like
after all why not
[Music]
why should I should die watch the plot
leaks and you son of a [ __ ] you're in
from here on out the secret Wars might
not be so secret without the way let's
get into the breakdown
[Music]
okay so in order for this to happen we
have to talk about what we've been told
plays out in Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania apparently the movie will
have us learning that Kang got stuck in
the quantum realm after Crash Landing
there whilst traveling through the
Multiverse his ship or rather chair will
be able to hop from Dimension to
Dimension and he'll have been traveling
through alternate realities in an
attempt to conquer them Kang will get
stuck there and he'll come across Janet
he'll start to help him fix his ship
before she finds out what he's really
after this will be why she doesn't want
to go back there and Scott will be hired
by Kang whilst they're down there to
find a device to bring his ship online
now from what I've been told Kang will
end up leaving the 616 at the end and
this will leave Scott and hope stranded
in the quantum realm during the movie
Kang will promise to travel through the
Multiverse devastating every reality
until he returns to the 616 to destroy
that last of all this is Judah Janet
messing his ship up earlier in the film
and leaving him stranded down there for
decades and decades okay Dynasty in
secret Wars will very much be the
culmination of this the first movie will
be about this version of Kang returning
and we'll learn about unconquering
worlds across the entire Multiverse this
will also introduce several of his
variants and it will very much be his
movie much in the same way that Infinity
war was thanos's we learn his backstory
as Nathaniel Richards see his Journey
Through Time and also watches the first
wave of Avengers attempts to take him
down this will be made up of characters
like xiongji Falcon Black Panther and so
on like I said this will apparently be
the first wave of characters to fight
him and the movie will culminate with
Kang winning which will cause the heroes
to have to reach out to the Multiverse
in order to get others again take this
all with a pinch of salt as it's still
very early days but I've had so many
people asking me to talk about what else
I was told in regards to the plans a Jin
Kang Dynasty will also be reintroduced
to he who remains you won't be called he
who remains because because you're not
the only one remaining yet he'll just be
named Nathaniel and he'll be on the team
of the good guys so of time you why me
wibbly wobbly stuff and technically to
him this is the first time he's
experiencing it now after the Avengers
are defeated we'll go into Secret Wars
which again is still getting worked on
though the fundamental plot details are
there this will center around he who
remains pulling together as many people
as he can from the Multiverse in order
to fight this giant war against Kang
it's a similar sort of thing to what the
Watcher did and what if and he'll be
traveling from Universe the universe and
getting as many people as he can now
when I did my last video I talked about
how far he was trying to get every major
character from a Marvel movie in the
film in some form or another there's a
number of franchises such as the fox
X-Men Universe Fantastic Four and so on
and they're aiming to get as many Heavy
Hitters as they can so your Hugh Jackman
Wolverines Andrew Garfield's Toby
Maguire's and so on they're who they're
really trying to nail down on a side
tangent Deadpool 3 will actually heavily
involve the TVA and it will also have
Owen Wilson returning as morbius as well
as Miss minutes Wilson's not returning
is Miss minutes you know what I mean now
this was teased out this week by Ryan
Reynolds on Twitter and slowly we're
gonna get all these characters slotted
into the MCU on the last video I did say
that Marvel's Studios were wanting a
similar sort of scene to the portals one
from Avengers end game I don't know if I
were to this badly or whatever but the
way the reports came out made it seem
like it'd be a copy and paste of the
portal scene what I meant though was
more the idea that everyone was on
screen at the same time this was pretty
much every major character from all the
MC movies up until that point with them
all standing shoulder to shoulder that's
more what they're aiming for with us
seeing every franchise on screen at the
same time all alongside each other ready
did you get out with Kang now I did get
told that the plan from then on was to
sign new contracts with some of the
stars and bring them into one
streamlined Universe the comics did this
too and when Marvel had lots of
different universes existing alongside
each other they did the big secret Wars
event and brought across the favorites
into one Universe miles Morales was
originally in the Ultimate Universe but
after the mega event he was pulled into
the main one where he's been ever since
this is the plan with Secret Wars 2 and
it's gonna allow for some of the X-Men
and so on to be brought across now
because of this being streamlined I'm
guessing the movie ends away that we've
already been told that takes us in a few
times
so the timeline being converged and the
inclusion of he who remains makes me
think there's only one way this plays
out and it's already been spoiled in
Loki you might remember that the he who
remains we met had been through this all
before to the point that he had a script
to show how everything was going to play
out therefore I think the movie will end
with the heroes having defeated Kang and
then he who remains will form the TVA
and he'll put things back in check from
here one timeline will start up again
and this will bring all the characters
together potentially Sylvie and Loki
will end up making different choices and
this Kang won't end up being created
that would be the perfect way to end the
Loki season as well and I do kind of
hope that that's the way things go time
travel shows and films in general
normally have the idea that when summing
is told to us that it can end up
happening no matter how much people try
and avoid it therefore I think that the
story that he who remains told us and
Loki will very much be the way that the
entire Secret Wars saga plays out anyway
that's in
just a theory mate don't don't come back
in three years and say it's wrong this
is just
either way this is gonna be the
Multiverse Saga and I've actually been
told there's a lot of movies that are
gonna have a big push towards this
without us initially thinking that
they'll have anything to do with it the
Marvels is a good example of this and
the Naga bands will play a big part in
it with them being able to pull things
across from other dimensions we saw this
very much with clandestines who came
from an alternate reality the bands will
be able to pull across characters and
resources however my sources have told
me that this will trigger an incursion
in the Marvels that will lead to bigger
things now when I say my source I'm
definitely not talking about my uncle
Patrick who works at the Disney Store in
Sunderland he definitely never saw an
email from HR when he was cleaning the
Bell Disney princess dresses and none of
this stuff should get him or anyone else
in trouble so I'm glad that's cleared up
and Patrick if if you're watching this
make start looking for another job like
a like yesterday anyway that's the video
and I hope you enjoyed it not massive
reveals uh just more me adding context
to what I was told so so some websites
can take the news run with it and get
way more views I suppose it's Christmas
though so I'll let it slide but in the
meantime I'd love to hear your thoughts
on what you want to see in the movie we
are in a competition right now and
giving away three copies of House of the
Dragon season one on the 15th of
December and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on drop a comment below
with your thoughts on the video you pick
the comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch we've got a video on screen right
now so definitely head over there right
after this click the button on YouTube
that says choose what's best for the
viewer so it's chosen that for you and
what does that say about you mate you
did you dirty scumbag anyway hopefully
I'll see you over there thanks for
sticking through us you take care bye